ra une journée de débats organisés par
sens commun ce mouvement qui à
l'intérieur deux des républicains
soutient les idées et les convictions de
la manif pour tous
il a parlé de la procréation
médicalement assistée et il a considéré
que c'était une forme d'eugénisme globo
est évidemment très fort voici les
arguments développés par laurent
wauquiez pour l'utiliser et s'étendre
linge mènera nécessairement à la
marchandisation des galettes à l'image
de ce site internet danoise cryos que
vous devriez aller voir la plus grande
bande de sphères du monde on vous pouvez
sélectionner
si vous voulez créer la peau blanche
vous battre
si vous voulez que ses yeux soit plus
ouvert si vous voulez que ses cheveux
soir ou à l'arrivée le panier d'achat
aura juste remplacer le caddie la zone
par ado mais c'est la seule différence
tout ceci a annoncé l'organisme tout
ceci est fait par un régime c'est le
nazisme
donc il a parlé de génisses me laurent
wauquiez la ministre de la santé agnès
buzyn à lui a répondu ce matin
elle l'a dit sur son compte twitter
c'est faux et archi faux
regardez aujourd'hui aucune politique
publique en france
et heureusement d'un devis de
l'eugénisme l'eugénisme je le rappelle
c'est le fait de vouloir faire une
sélection génétique pour aboutir à des
hommes parfaits c'était effectivement ce
que souhaitait faire les nazis homme
parfait entre guillemets et évidemment
aucun acte médical en france ne peut
conduire à l'eugénisme s'est dévoyé le
sens des mots c'est irresponsable pour
un soi disant responsables politiques et
je voulais faire part de mon indignation
alors nous versons un élément au dossier
nous sommes allés sur ce site internet à
cryos tombe dans par laurent wauquiez
et ce qui est vrai après vous nous direz
c'est le g10 moon on sait que vous
pouvez choisir à la carte
on a expliqué qu'on était français et
on l'a demandé voilà on cherche on
cherche un donneur et on nous dit quelle
race quelle couleur de cheveux
quel est le poids du donneur son origine
ethnique la couleur des yeux
donc c'est vraiment le bébé sur mesure
est ce que c'est une forme d'eugénisme
ça frédéric dabi même si le mot fait
peur
je pense que oui là c'est la question la
plus inouïe le site est particulièrement
spectaculaire
on n'a rien inventé sinon normalement
d'affaires tous là ces derniers 6-2
enfin je dirais je vois deux soucis dans
ce qu'a dit laurent wauquiez
le souci c'est que on est quand même
loin du débat sur la pma ou c'est vrai
qu'une majorité de français la
soutiennent sauf effectivement
l'électorat de françois fillon
l'élection présidentielle sur cette
question par rapport au mariage pour
tous les clivages se sont très fortement
atténué deuxième effet c'est plus un
effet collatéral voilà laurent wauquiez
fait faute d'actualité sur une
thématique qui n'est pas au coeur des
préoccupations des français
il ya une dimension de brouillage de son
discours nous n'attendons pas en tant
que chef d'un des principaux partis
d'opposition
sur les questions dont on vient de
parler a précédemment notamment la
mobilisation des filets jaunes le
pouvoir d'achat et la critique frontale
de l'action du président de la
république sait je réponds un petit peu
décalé mais très décalé par rapport au
discours et des français et à la période
sur le mot lui même
olivia bobo quand j'ai entendu cette
expression me suis dit non c'est trop
fort effectivement année ce butin disait
le génie c'est la volonté d'avoir
l'homme parfait et voilà on n'est pas là
sauf qu effectivement on se dit si des
couples de lesbiennes veulent avoir un
donneur de sperme et que l on recourt à
un site comme celui là bas on est quand
même dans une forme d'eugénisme ou pas
votre avis oui mais je crois que c'est
très difficile non contestable le génie
c'est passe réellement l'homme parfait
six ans et l'homme sélectionner ses
sélectionnés certaines odeurs on part on
parle du nazisme et les spartiates le
faisait quand il éliminer les bébés
qu'ils estiment pas bon et puis on le
fait depuis très très longtemps parce
que on demande aux maires quand on leur
dit votre enfant a une chance d'être
atteint 2
de trisomie 21 est ce que voulaient les
supprimer dans 99% des cas on le fait
donc l'eugénisme suis désolé il existe
déjà
le vrai problème à l'occasion du débat
sur la pma c'est que finalement on se
rend compte que les techniques de
sélection on va les avoir
elles vont être de plus en plus forte et
récemment lors il est peut-être une case
qui va s'ajouter mais c'est le cuit
c'est à dire vous allez pouvoir choisir
des parents qui vont avoir un certain qu
on sait que cuit en partie héréditaire
et puis vous allez pouvoir
de plus en plus sélectionnés chez vos
enfants ce genre de caractéristiques on
est bien loin de la taille et de la
couleur des yeux
il ya beaucoup de caractéristiques et la
question c'est qu'aujourd'hui évidemment
on pourra mettre toutes les barrières
réglementaires qu'on veut c'est que ça
va être très facile de faire ça ailleurs
d'aller dans des endroits avec beaucoup
moins de scrupules et en chine par
exemple ils ont très peu scrupuleux
vis-à-vis de ça on va pouvoir
sélectionner donc la capacité
scientifique on va l'avoir
et le fait qu'on va pouvoir le faire et
que des gens vont le faire ça c'est
probablement ce qui arrive on est sur le
toboggan et génique à toute vitesse
il faudrait qu on ouvre les yeux qu'on
arrête de pousser des cris d'orfraie
comme si ce n'était pas vrai c'est la
réalité il est probablement temps qu'on
ait un débat réel sur la question parce
que c'est quelque chose qui nous arrive
dans les mois qui viennent c'est déjà
probablement là et le débat en louvre
ici c'est aussi cela la mission de point
de vue caroline valentin votre opinion
sur ce sujet mon opinion c'est que
laurent wauquiez a fait ça le révoquer a
du mal à avoir un projet bien cadré et
donc il court un peu après l'actualité
ils essaient de faire paraît évident les
médias donc plus on prend des mots à
forte connotation émotionnelle puis ça
marche donc en fait c'est simplement un
épisode de politique politicienne cette
grande commedia dell'arte politique ou
lui parle de génisses m'ont pardonné
dans les médias puis macro s'insurge en
à cran et ses sbires s'insurge la pas
très intéressant en fait alors ce qui
est intéressant peut-être c'est si on
prend un pot si on fait un pas en
arrière et qu'on réfléchisse aux débats
de fond il ya deux choses à dire
premièrement que génisses ppm a
fondamentalement sont quand même deux
sujets différents et qu' il ya des
sujets à évoquer au sujet de la pma des
pma son père surtout que
que laurent wauquiez ont été bien
inspirés de développer un peu plus
effectivement ensuite il ya ce sujet de
l'eugénisme et c'est un sujet qui est
discutée par plein de grands
intellectuels
malheureusement on a l'impression que
les hommes politiques les responsables
politiques n'entendent pas ces
intellectuels mais notamment il ya je
crois c'est xavier comment il s'appelle
ce xxiè klein que je crois qu'ils
parlaient de la différence entre
l'innovation et le progrès il disait le
mot progrès a disparu en fait du
vocabulaire intellectuelle et maintenant
on ne parle que d'innovation or c'est
pas la même chose puisque le progrès
c'est une aspiration à un monde meilleur
on définit là on veut aller et on se
donne les moyens d'y aller alors que
l'innovation c'est ondes et à ce moment
présent et puis on essaie de s'en
échapper et finalement sans savoir où on
va donc il ya une façon peut-être plus
intelligente plus sereine plus un peu
comme macron l'avait fait aux bernardins
de dire qu' il faut de la philosophie et
qu'on doit il faut réfléchir que les
ossements à cette espèce de
d'accélération scientifique et de
l'innovation technologique qui nous
conduit en seo le point de vue dollars
qui lui dit je connais très bien ce
sujet dans ma famille il y a deux
enfants issus de la pma là maman a
vraiment choisi ses enfants en fonction
de l'homme tandis qu'en t-mac estime que
laurent wauquiez a raison sur le fond
mais qu'il n'aurait pas dû dire
eugénie sme périco légasse votre point
de vue laurent wauquiez a l'habitude de
faire des déclarations dans des milieux
confinés où ils pensent que ne l'entend
pas il est en terrain conquis avec avec
sens commun voilà ils pouvaient pas se
tromper
là où il faut comprendre le mécanisme de
sa pensée et c'est vrai et je voyais à
l'instant le communiqué de benjamin
griveaux qu'ils ont tout le monde garde
le cap à la république en marche
on sait pas avec quelqu'un qu'on fait on
garde le cap à savoir on se tiendra
strictement à la pma mais en vos coeurs
des donneurs de sperme il a rappelé
quand il ya eu le pack sans nous a dit
il n'y aura pas le mariage pour tous je
me souviens d'un homme politique qui
parlait solennellement devant les
français ignorent quand on a fait le
paillage pour tous je me souviens
président il n'y aura pas de pma la
classe politique mais au parti
socialiste
et quand on fait la pma on le dit il n'y
aura pas de gestation pour autrui
général bye heureuse par autrui de mère
porteuse
là c'est pas seulement combat
l'eugénisme qui est aujourd'hui un acte
mais on est en train de préparer bientôt
il y aura même plus besoin d'eux il y
aura des guides et des gamètes et les
embryons tout près qu'on ira chercher
dans des commerces
ça va se faire ça existe déjà donc c'est
pas le génie ce moto course et le g10 le
maire cantine parce qu'on trouvera un
moyen de commercialiser cette génisse
pour faire du profit et on choisira
ensuite qui on veut et comme on veut
c'est une remise en cause de l'humanité
de façon absolument tragique pour
satisfaire une minorité à laquelle je
reconnais le droit effectivement d'avoir
envie d'être parents mais c'est toujours
précieux pour satisfaire immunité qu'on
remet en cause un ordre de l'humanité un
ordre mondial qu'il faut être pensés
avec des lois de bioéthique beaucoup
plus subtilement est beaucoup plus
délicatement que d'aller comme ça le
progrès cette franchise à chaque fois un
stade on est au pacs on est aux portes
de la gpa mais c'est le sens du progrès
c'est le sens de l'histoire non ça peut
être aussi une régression barque et de
l'innovation
innovation est en marche
on sait que le sujet est compliqué pour
le garmin skil a décidé de remettre à
l'année prochaine le monachisme le noir
la gpa est interdite en france
elle se fait aux états unis oui mais là
donc mais qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire contre ça il ya eu le mois dernier
à cet animateur qui a fait beaucoup de
médias pour écarter olivier français
très amis
normal voilà c'est vrai que là aussi ont
une fois de plus la france n'est pas
donc le fauga la gpa sais je choisis le
profil de mon enfance je veux tel
quotient je veux qu'ils la blanquette de
veau qui lisent le figaro et qu'ils
fassent de la course à pied et que voilà
et qu'elle apprécie périco légasse
certainement ce soit forcément de
qualité qui ont été faits à l'étranger
un dernier commentaire de 10 kw qui
disent non déplaise laurent wauquiez a
raison car quand on peut choisir son
futur enfant
selon des critères et bien on le fait il
nous reste quelques minutes pour parler
d'un sujet plus léger
airbnb vous savez ce ce site internet
qui propose à la location des logements
privés c'est un succès considérable bien
de baisser à 10 ans rien qu'au troisième
trimestre 2010 8
il ya eu 400 millions de personnes qui
ont utilisé les services de ce site il
paraît en tout cas c'est les chiffres
d'airbnb que 20 1 français sur 5 et
clients delà de la plate forme alors les
responsables politiques en tout cas
certains d'entre eux ont mis en place un
certain nombre de mesures pour contrer
airbnb c'est le cas des députés qui ont
voté en fin de semaine dernière dans le
cadre du budget 2010 neuf de nouvelles
sanctions contre les propriétaires qui
louent par airbnb mais qui ne satisfont
pas les nouvelles taxes il ya une taxe
de séjour il ya aussi une surtaxe de 15%
en ile de france il ya un maximum de 120
nuits par an l'objectif il est clair
c'est de ne pas laisser à bienne be trop
se développer c'est aussi celui de ian
brossât qui est le l'adjoint au logement
d'anne hidalgo l'adjointe communiste au
logement et qui sont expliquées
d'ailleurs très ouvertement en septembre
dernier dans l'hyper centre de paris
aujourd'hui